Film Courage: Actually, the line I was going
to use was not that line, it was, excuse my
language here, fix your sh$t before you waste
someone else’s time.
Which I loved (from the movie), that line.
But it can be applied to many things, not
just a relationship and so that is where I
was going with this….Tyler Johnson: That’s
funny you say that, because it’s sort of
my excuse on why I don’t date right now.
It’s not other people, it’s me fixing….since
we’re now speaking in French…me fixing
my own sh$t before I just on load on to someone
else.
It does apply to relationships, you want to
be able to give someone your all, you want
to give them your time and attention, when
you’re after a pursuit like this, your time
and attention is hard to come by.
Film Courage: Very true.
And that’s why I was saying, it is a lonely
journey when you focus solely on something,
whether it’s an entrepreneur or we’ve
talked to people who were working in tech
or different similar professions and it is
a lonely thing because people end up falling
away because you’re busy trying to do stuff
and it’s not because maybe they’re mad
at you but you just isolate yourself.
Pascal Payant: The best example are the
people that are always surrounded by people,
they are so afraid to face themselves and
that is what I think is the most gratifying.
That when you have that…you can totally
get everything that is on your way and just
break through them but as soon as you are
afraid to face yourself, face your demons,
there is no way you’re going to be able
to make it in this business.
You are just going to be pushed left and right
and be so scared and scream “Oh, I want
to quit.
Where’s my Plan B.” Film Courage: And
it can be applied to filmmaking, as well.
So fixing your…whatever…stuff before you….
Pascal: Being focused.
That’s the main thing.
Tyler: And it’s also, acting is sort of
beautiful in the sense that any problems that
you have in your personal life will manifest
in your work.
And the weaknesses, the proclivities, all
those things, they show up in the work.
And so the work becomes sort of the ground
with which you address these things within
yourself and so the take away is pretty remarkable
if you’re really putting yourself into the
work that you’re doing the amount that you
can learn about the way that you approach
problems or the way that you react in situations….I
mean I know I was surprised over the course
of the film, especially considering going
back to the audition, vulnerability, I mean
how easy it was for me at the end to just
fly off the handle at the character Alyssa.
I mean it was cathartic in a way, but it also
surprised me and it was something since then
I’ve really gotten to know intimately that
side of myself, a side that maybe I denied
before I met Pascal and did this film.
Film Courage: They say that therapists should
also be in therapy, do you think that actors
should be in therapy?
Because there are things that maybe you’re
blind to…they say we have this shadow self
that maybe we don’t see.
Pascal: But I think acting or doing a film….for
him, I think he was going through something
when we did the film, a lot of things, but
he brought that, and it worked.
And sometimes it didn’t work and I had
to refocus him a little bit, but when sometimes
he was in this dark zone, he just fed from
it and it worked.
So I think screw therapy, just act in a film
or something like that.
Tyler: I only laughed at the therapy line
because I think that maybe actors shouldn’t
be in therapy only because I feel like the
greatest gift that you can give audiences
in that vulnerable messy, chaotic, ugly side
of yourself.
Pascal: And you want to discover yourself
takes after takes after takes and if you know
all the answers right away, there is nothing
left to be discovered.
Tyler: I don’t even know if there is such
as thing as a well-balanced actor.
Pascal: And I don’t trust it….
Tyler: Or artists, maybe in general.
Film Courage: So if you’re one of these
keep calm and carry on type people, then that’s
not really going to translate?
Tyler: I mean if it works, then God bless
you.
I’m sure there are people who can prove
me wrong on that and if so, caps off to you.
But I’d say for everybody else, let your
freak flag fly.
(Pascal and Tyler laughing..)
Question: Do you agree that an actor’s
personal problems manifest in their work?